[Applause]
Kanye Sunday service seems to grow
bigger and bigger each week and it's
apparently turning into even more of a
family affair
Kasane West is now a singing in the
choir
[Music]
yeah that's three year old st. in front
with big sister North Kim Kardashian
shared the clip writing quote this was
Saints first time so North wanted to
make sure he knew the words she's so
nice to say now lol ha it's funny
because Kim hinted to et that this
wasn't always the case
yo goes up and down she definitely has
been better since the little baby is
here but there st. and Chicago's
relationship is so sweet that I don't I
don't know what's gonna top that so it's
actually really cute and so is this
video that Kim shared also from Sunday
service north on Kanye's shoulders but
while North definitely seems super
musical it might be her mama she takes
after
is she a beauty mogul in the making will
she take over for you one day you know I
actually had to put her on our PR list
and get her her own set of makeup this
time because she's destroys all of mine
when she sees it and then I can't use it
for myself so she she definitely loves
makeup if she loves it enough she can
definitely take it over whatever she
wants to do when she is old enough she
can do but her new favorite thing ever
is no one in the room no adults closing
the door with one of her friends or her
dolls and doing makeovers and no one can
see until the final look is done or
she'll freak out and cry
feels like Kim and Kanye have their
hands full they also just welcomed baby
number four song but the inspiration was
the Book of Psalms in the Bible so I
think it's just a wonderful way to
celebrate you know how they feel and
he's such a blessing so it's perfect
all right guys do we think any of Kim
and Kanye's kids are headed for a career
and music let me know and for all the
latest on the Kardashians make sure you
keep it locked to all things et until
next time I'm Katie grass and bye for
now
[Applause]
[Music]